معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد بعد ارتفاع عدد قتلى الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى
192 قتيل منذ بدايه العمليه البريه ما
التساؤلات التي تطرح في اسرائيل بهذا
الخصوص لا سما عندما يكشف التحقيق الاولي
بان تفجير الشاحنه سببه اطلاق نار من
دبابه
اسرائيليه 14 ضابطا وجنديا من هؤلاء قتلوا
منذ بدايه العام الحالي ونحن في اليوم
العاشر منه تسعه كان قد اعلن الجيش عنهم
يوم امس ومن بينهم السته جنود وضباط الذين
قتلوا جراء ما قال الجيش حسب تحقيقاته
بانه قصف من دبابه اصاب عمود كهرباء وان
شظيه او شراره اصابت شاحنه تحمل متفجرات
كانت مجهزه لنسف انفاق ومصنع للصواريخ
بعيده المدى لكتائب القسام في منطقه
البريج هذا خطا جديد يسجله الجيش
الاسرائيلي او فشل في اطار معاركه
وتسلسلها المتصاعد في قطاع غزه ويضع علامه
سؤال من وجهه النظر الاسرائيليه على
الاداء اداء العسكري كانت هناك سلسله
مقابله وقعت في منطقه حي الشجاعيه في حينه
واشتهرت كثيرا وهو الحي الشرقي لمدينه غزه
الان ياتي الجيش ليعلن ان هناك ايضا خطا
جديد ويقول الخبراء في اسرائيل انه يعكس
حاله من الارتباك في داخل واوسا قواته
تحديدا في منطقه وسط قطاع غزه وجنوبها
التي ما زالت تشهد تواصلا وتكثيف للعمليات
البريه الاسرائيليه او كما قال المتحدثون
باسمه فوق الارض وتحت الارض ويقول انه على
الرغم من ذلك سيواصل حربه ويواصل قتاله في
هذه المنطقه واعلن صباح اليوم عن انه وسع
ما وصفها بالمناور البريه في اشاره
لعملياته وحربه البريه تحديدا في منطقه
خان يونس وانها ستستمر رغم ذلك حتى يصل
الى قاده حماس وقاده كتائب القسام وان
يحقق اهدافه كامله هذا ياتي في وقت كان من
المفترض ان يبدا فيه بدا فيه الحقيقه
الجيش الاسرائيلي ما وصفها بالمرحله
الثالثه من حربه البريه على قطاع غزه لكن
انه حصرها فقط في المناطق الشماليه وهي لم
تكن وفق ما اتفق عليه مع الامريكيين بان
يكون هناك اعاده انتشار وانسحاب الى داخل
المناطق الحدوديه داخل القطاع وانما اكتفى
بالبقاء على تخوم المناطق السكنيه التي
دمرها في شمالي قطاع غزه و وظل يحضر ويمنع
عوده المواطنين الفلسطينيين الذين نزحوا
عنها يمنع عودتهم اليها
المعارك حاليا ووفق التصريحات سواء الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي او وزير الدفاع جلنت
او غيرهم من المحللين المرتبطين بالجيش
تشير الى ان المعارك هناك ضاريه ومتواصله
وعلى نطاق واسع هناك اجتياحات اضافيه في
قلب مدينه خانيونس او كما وصفتها بعض
مصادره تسويه المباني بالارض على حد
تعبيرهم لكن واضح بان الخسائر التي ارتفعت
في الايام الاخيره باتت تثقل على الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي يعلن على الرغم من ذلك
انه سيواصل وسط وجود اصوات متفاوته في
الشارع الاسرائيلي ذوي ال اسرائيليين
المحتجزين في قطاع غزه يواصلون المطالبه
بوقف العمليات ووقف اطلاق النار من اجل
استعاده ابنائهم واقربائهم المحتجزين
ويقدر عددهم بنحو
136 بينما هناك تيار اخر يبدو ان انه مقرب
من رئيس الوزراء يدعو الى استمرار هذه
الحرب بكل ضراوه وعدم توقفها حتى تحقيق
اهدافها في جميع الاحوال واضح بان الحرب
وان دخلت مرحلتها الثالثه لكنها
ستتواصل خاصه في مناطق جنوبي قطاع غزه
الذي يسيطر عليه الجيش الاسرائيلي الى حد
كبير برا وجوا وبحرا لكن هذا لم يمنع
كتائب القسام والمقاومه من ان تطلق
الصواريخ خاصه امس الاول عندما استهدفت
منطقه تل ابيب الكبرى والمناطق جنوبها نحو
20 بلده ومدينه بصواريخ بعيده المدى كان
مجرد عمليه اطلاقها هو الذي اشار الى انها
ما زالت قادره على التحكم او اداره شانها
في هذه الحرب وهو ما شكل في حينه نوع من
المفاجاه لصناع القرار في اسرائيل الذين
اعتقدوا بان كتائب القسام على وجه الخصوص
قد فقدت جزء كب كبيرا من قدرتها الصاروخيه
وجاء هذا القصف ليقلب الامور من جديد
ثانيا الجيش الاسرائيلي تحدث عن انه ضبط
ودمر مخرطه ومصنعا للصواريخ بعيده المدى
في منطقه البريج لكن الانفجار الذي جاء
واعلن عنه في سياره للذخيره في تلك
المنطقه وسط قطاع غزه ايضا كما يبدو انه
عاد وشوش او عرقل بعض حساباته بهذا الخصوص
لذلك اعلن عن تعزيز قواته واستمرار عملها
في جنوبي القطاع وتحديدا خانيونس والمناطق
الوسطى ولكنه انتقل الى المرحله
الثالثه المتفق معها مع الجانب الامريكي
في شمال قطاع غزه هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى ما زال الاسرائيليون انفسهم الذين
نزحوا عن مناطق غلاف غزه عدد كبير منهم
يرفض العوده لانهم يقولون بان لم يت تحقق
الامن لهم حتى الساعه وان هذه الحرب لا
يبدو ان لها نهايه والجيش الاسرائيلي لم
يحقق اي من ان اهدافه التي كان قد تحدث
عنها وهذا ايضا يربك حزاب المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين يربك حساباتهم وهو ما حاولوا
اقناع وزير الخارجيه بلينكن بامره امس
وكان يختلف معهم بين الحين والاخر لكن
واضح بان مساله قطاع غزه ما زالت هي التي
تتصدر ال الامور عسكريا وسياسيا ايضا
وهناك محاولات كانت من جانب القيادات
الاسرائيليه والجيش الاسرائيلي الاظهار
للشارع الاسرائيلي انهم يحققون تقدما لكن
عدد الذين قتلوا منذ بدايه هذا العام
وتحديدا امس الاول يبدو انه عاد ووضع
علامه سؤال كبيره امام الاسرائيليين اذاء
رواياتهم الرسميه سواء العسكريه ام
السياسيه بخصوص واقع الحال بالمعارك في
قطاع غز